zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
jetzt geht es plötzlich ganz schnell
schon am wochenende sollen alle die die
schon mal corona hatten oder geimpft
wurden viele freiheiten wieder
zurückbekommen damit rechnet die
bundesjustizministerin bundestag und
bundesrat müssten bis ende der woche
noch zustimmen und einzelne bundesländer
wollen lockern bayern zum beispiel und
unter anderem und sogar urlaub über
pfingsten scheint jetzt möglich ist dass
zu schnell ist das zu früh ist das
gefährlich ist das zu verantworten
darüber sprechen wir hier heute abend
und zwar tun wir das mit nelson müller
er ist fernsehkoch hier im zdf vielen
bekannt aus der küchenschlacht und
gastronom und hat sich schon auch zu
diesem thema viel geäußert unter anderem
auch in einer talkshow in der karl
lauterbach war das heißt es ist schön
dass sie beide sich heute abend auch
hier bei uns im stream wiedertreffen
doktor karl lauterbach der
spd-gesundheitsexperte vielen dank dass
sie bei uns heute abend mit dabei sind
und auch sie zuhause herzlich willkommen
wir freuen uns über ihre fragen und
kommentare wie immer in die kommentare
oder wenn sie die zdf- heute- app nutzen
an diese e mail adresse bevor wir
miteinander sprechen schauen wir vorüber
julia schröter passt das zusammen
die zahl der geimpften steigt damit
werden die rufe nach lockerungen für
geimpfte und genesene immer lauter das
kabinett hat heute entsprechende pläne
beschlossen
danach darf wer vollständig geimpft oder
genesen ist nachts unterwegs sein
trotz ausgangs beschränkungen sich mit
weniger einschränkungen mit anderen
treffen und ohne test beispielsweise
läden museen oder auch friseure besuchen
schon am wochenende könnte all das
gelten bis dahin sollen bundestag und
bundesrat zugestimmt haben
der nachweis für die impfung erfolgt
über den impfausweis oder ein
entsprechendes papier bald soll das auch
digital geben dass man genießen ist muss
man ebenfalls belegen mit einem nachweis
über einen positiven pcr labortest die
erkrankung muss mindestens 28 tage
zurückliegen aber nicht länger als sechs
monate lauter war darf nach ihrer
meinung jeder der geimpft ist ab dem
wochenende wieder zu herrn müller ins
restaurant also eher müller würde ich
ihnen also nicht lassen und da sehe ich
zu sagen so leiten das auch nicht desto
trotz also darf man sich also abends war
bewegen die ausgangsbedingungen geht
nicht in gruppen auftreten wo er nicht
angerechnet wird also was die
ausgangsbedingungen vorsehen
was sich nicht mehr als viele leute
treffen können und wurde er dazu kommen
dürfen ohne dass er nicht gezählt wird
und also wenn es jetzt möglich wir
erwarten und weise in einem safe run zu
gehen oder in einen außengastronomie
bereich wo man eigentlich einen anti gen
test benötigte dann durfte er dort auch
hin ohne dass dieser test gemacht werden
müsste aber wenn das was dort
grundsätzlich noch geschlossen ist also
auch mit antigenen festung noch nicht
geöffnet ist dann wirkt er auch nicht in
das land
warum keinen restaurantbesuch für
geimpfte hat am 8 das wäre dann ja die
idee dass man restaurantbesuche nur
vergebens gemacht denn für die nicht
geimpften kommt das ja nicht in frage
weil innenbereich des restaurants auch
dann noch zu gefährlich ist wenn man im
antiken torso getesteten oder somit also
wenn dann die gegend fest und impfung
gleich setzen müssen beide was und
innenbereich an die frau zu bleiben wenn
man jetzt hört würde sagen gehört dann
die restaurants für diejenigen die mit
antigenen festen fest sind dann dürfte
auch der ergebnisse in das fenster
hinein aber solange das noch nicht
vertretbar ist und die derzeitigen
zahlen geben das noch nicht mehr muss
auch der also kämpfte sich noch ein paar
wochen gedulden bis wir so viele teams
haben dass dem tatsächlich so etwas für
alle vertreten können auch diejenigen
die an hand gehen herr müller bevor sie
gleich die frage beantworten
bitte inwiefern sich das denn für sie
lohnen würde und attraktiv wäre für
geimpfte das restaurant zu öffnen müssen
sie uns bitte ganz kurz erklären was die
geräusche sind die wir bei ihnen im
hintergrund werden denn das hört sich so
an wie ein geräusch das wir schon lange
nicht mehr gehört haben nämlich ein
restaurant in dem gekocht wird können
sie uns das ganz kurz einordnen ja sehr
gerne ich sitze hier tatsächlich jetzt
in gast bereich unseres gourmet
restaurants und da wir eine offene küche
haben hört man jetzt hier schöner weise
auch das töpfe klappern und das gekochte
denn wir machen auch wenn wir natürlich
im restaurant nicht eröffnen können aber
trotzdem turbo geschäft für unsere gäste
werden tolle und viele stammgäste die
das auch nutzen und nutzen alle
möglichkeiten vom liefern bis zur
abholung bis zu den einschlägigen
diensten die das dann eben auch abholen
und zu den gästen bringen und das hat
man jetzt einfach super dann wissen wir
dass herr müller dankeschön dann würde
ich gleich gern die erste frage aus dem
chat an sie weitergeben oslo fragt über
youtube lohnt es sich zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ausschließlich für vollständig
geimpften die gastronomie zu öffnen auch
bei sehr hoher intelligenz und
wenn nicht ab welchem zeitpunkt würde es
sich lohnen das ist jetzt erst mal also
quasi die frage nach der
wirtschaftlichkeit und vielleicht können
sie aber auch anschließend was ihre
position es würden sie es denn überhaupt
wollen
ja ja ich glaube wenn ich zunächst die
frage zur wirtschaftlichkeit beantworten
darf auch das turbo geschäft ist
natürlich nicht einseitig nur von einer
wirtschaftlichen seite heraus zu sehen
sondern man muss und ich glaube das wird
eben oft auch vergessen die ganzen
weichen komponenten eben auch mit
einbeziehen das bedeutet die die
möglichkeit mitarbeiter aus der
kurzarbeit zu holen diese mitarbeiter
eben auch nicht zu verlieren dann ist es
auch ein trend jetzt absolut gerade in
der gastronomie dass viele mitarbeiter
den eben auch abwandern weil sie
psychologisch das nicht mehr aushalten
zu hause zu bleiben oder sich nicht mehr
gebraucht führen oder eben auch selber
wirtschaftliche einbußen haben und dann
auch in andere branchen abwandern
also ist das ist ein wichtiger aspekt
dann ein zweiter aspekt ist natürlich
auch sind auch unsere stammgäste oder
gäste überhaupt die wir natürlich auch
dadurch halten dass es daneben auch in
die zukunft gerichtet vielleicht nicht
im moment jetzt wirtschaftlich lohnend
aber in die zukunft gerichtet verlieren
wir den gast nicht den wir sonst uns
mühsam geben wir wieder arbeiten wenn
wir auch machen denn das hat der letzte
noch dann auch gezeigt dass es nicht so
ist dass jeder sofort bereitwillig ohne
zögern wieder ins restaurant geht
sondern viele sind auch ängstlich und
überlegen erstmal und schauen sich
erstmal an und sind da jetzt auch
gewohnt im zu hause zu bleiben und sind
dann vielleicht auch erst mal noch in
dem trott und es dauert auch wieder
seine zeit bis die restaurants wieder so
voll werden das heißt die kundenbindung
ist auch dazu extrem wichtig und dann
ist es aber auch ein gemisch und die die
hilfen die es ja gibt gott sei dank
richten sich ja letztendlich nach den
umsatz-einbußen so das heißt wenn man
jetzt die trasse öffnen würde auch das
restaurant für nur eine kleine
zielgruppe öffnen würde hätte man schon
einen
wirtschaftliches parameter nachdem er
das steuerberater sagen kann ok das
haben jetzt den umsatz seiner gemacht
der wird verglichen mit dem umsatz 2009
10 das ja das referenzjahr nachdem sich
zum beispiel die bedrückung hilfe 3
richtet und dann kann man ganz genau
sehen okay das haben wir gemacht das
hätten wir normalerweise gemacht das
sind die umsatzrückgänge und danach
richten sich daneben die hilfen also
sind es dann kann man schon sagen dass
sich eben auch einen öffnen unter
eingeschränkten bedingungen lohnen würde
jetzt kommen wir zur moralischen frage
hier legt nochmal stl 1988 auch über
youtube nach ehrlich gesagt ist es viel
zu früh geimpften jetzt mehr rechte
wiederzugeben so lange sich noch nicht
alle impfen lassen dürfen wie
beantworten sie diese frage für sich als
gastronom
ja das ist eine sehr schwierige frage
die ich auch bei der ich auch noch das
eine oder andere nacht drüber nachdenken
muss aber im ersten moment glaube ich
haben wir vielleicht auch ein
logistisches problem wenn wir wirklich
sagen wir warten jetzt bis wirklich ganz
viele geimpft sind und vielleicht tut es
uns auch so zu sagen wir starten schon
mal in irgendeiner form und und üben das
ja auch als auch da werden wir auch noch
unsere erfahrungen machen müssen wie das
ist wenn wir die apps benutzen wie luca
app oder was auch immer
systeme mit denen wir dann das eben auch
logistisch regeln und da ist die frage
ob das so schlau ist es dann zu machen
wenn ganz viele geimpft sind und alle
plötzlich wieder in die restaurants
strömen oder ob man dann nicht mehr
gewinnt wenn man das vielleicht doch
jetzt schon macht und ich finde das
immer zu vergleichen die in so einer
familie wenn man sich überlegt ich bin
in der familie und habe die jetzt muss
ich müssen wir gemeinsam festlegen wer
darf jetzt schon was machen weil oder
müssen jetzt alle drunter leiden weil
der eine etwas nicht darf und ich glaube
da würde man sich wahrscheinlich auch er
solidarisch zeigen und sagen komm dann
geht doch schon mal raus und machte doch
schon mal du musst jetzt nicht auf uns
warten
das ist natürlich eine moralisch absolut
schwierige frage aber ich würde
tendenziell eher sagen lieber schon mal
früher anfangen und uns schauen wie man
das dann eben auch hinbekommt natürlich
nicht ohne die perspektive dass die
anderen dann eben auch bald frei gewählt
werden können
herr lauterbach in den chats kommt sehr
oft die frage nach der infektiosität von
geimpften und die ist natürlich relevant
dafür wenn man überlegt was dürfen denn
geimpfte überhaupt denn sie dürfen ja
nur viel wenn man davon ausgeht dass von
ihnen keine gefahr ausgeht erwin
schönstedt schreibt zum beispiel auch
über youtube können sie konkret sagen um
wie viel prozent geimpfte weniger
infektiös sind als ungeimpfte und welche
konkreten studien liegen ihre antwort zu
grunde ja vielen dank zunächst einmal
eine sehr wichtige frage muss man
unterscheiden zwischen den zwar einmal
so vollständig geimpften und den reihen
bei geimpften und das was ich sage
bezieht sich nur auf die zahlen wirklich
gute routinedaten haben wir dazu nur aus
england sondern in england habe ich an
diese wichtige auswertung gegeben von
den geimpften die mit astrazeneca
geworden sind und auch mit biotech die
durch die wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass
man sich überhaupt infiziert nachdem man
geben es war und wie hoch die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass man also
dann so infiziert ist dass man auch
symptome hat und so wie hoch der
sogenannte ct wert ist also der dann
also darüber hinaus eine auskunft gibt
wie ansteckend ist manche andere
um es kurz zu machen das hat sich also
gezeigt dass diejenigen die sich trotz
impfung anstecken
in der regel an cd wert haben über 30
das bedeutet durchschnittlich um die 32
das bedeutet sie sind wahrscheinlich
nicht anstecken
während sie ansteckend sind dann sind es
kann es super später und sie werden dann
sicherlich nicht ansteckend wenn man die
normalen abstandsregeln maske hält aber
nichtsdestotrotz was man kann nicht
sagen dass geimpfte sich nicht
infizieren können das können sie sie
können sich infizieren
das risiko geht zum beispiel bei
astrazeneca um etwa 80 prozent gesenkt
aber da bleibt halt 120 prozent risiko
übrig mindestens und dass sie die so
infizierten sind der dienst dann
deutlich weniger ansteckend weil die
wirklich sehr ansteckenden ctn etr die
legend unter 30 zur erinnerung die
niedriger der cd wird also desto
ansteckender ist der betroffene und cd
werte über 30 im bereich 30
30 sind in der regel ein zeichen dafür
dass man nicht wirklich ansteckend ist
also dass somit der einzelnen ist rein
stecken deshalb kein superstar mehr und
er wurde somit auch zum beispiel in
einer gruppe wo er also fünf sechs leute
trifft würde er wahrscheinlich nicht die
fünf oder sechs leute anstecken der wahl
dass er sowas bei der leicht macht was
ist denn weil sie das gerade
angesprochen haben wenn jemand nur
einfach geimpft ist das geht in richtung
einer frage die michelle zum beispiel
stellt ist das treffen unter geimpften
ungefährlich auch wenn die beteiligten
nur einfach geimpft sind
wir erleben ja jetzt im moment und in
ein paar wochen oder tagen werden sehr
viele leute ein erstes impfangebot haben
das heißt wir werden sehr viele erst
geimpfte haben österreich zum beispiel
sagt wir machen wieder auf und eine
corona erstimpfung 21 tage nach dem
erhalt der ersten dosis gilt als
eintrittskarte für restaurants
veranstaltungen oder hotels wie schätzen
sie das ein ist das eine gute idee
nun hat das ist keine gute idee
epidemiologisch macht das gar keine sind
so eigenes derjenige der nur einmal
geimpft wurde
wer also ist viel weniger geschützt und
kann sich durchaus noch anstecken
weil es kommt doch seien sehr stark auf
den impfstoff anders und auch die
mutation mit der man sich ansteckt aber
wenn man dann pech hat und das infiziert
sich mit einer mutation und hat
beispielsweise astrazeneca impfstoff
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man
sich ansteckt noch relativ hoch nach der
einmal irgendwo verband ist es nicht
viel besser somit also geht das ganze
aber viel wichtiger so ein anderes
problem
was also hier die vorgehensweise in
österreich als sehr riskant erscheinen
lässt und zwar während derjenige der es
sich jetzt also hat einmal eben
verlassen sich infiziert das sind genau
die infektionen die im prinzip mutations
ausbreitung im land wahrscheinlicher
machen war gegen alle solche einmal
impfung können sie sich am besten die
mutationen durchsetzen
ja so genanntes es geht phänomen haben
zum beispiel die also veränderungen am
genom
bezeichnung 448 ca beispielsweise
beschallt oder epilepsie lawn gibt es
auch diese also veränderungen also
zeichnen also an klerus aus was sich
also bei diensten besser durchsetzt dann
hätten diese mutationen einen
selektionsvorteil und so etwas ja so
kann man so etwas kann man nicht also
wirklich also wollen
somit würde eine solche strategie dass
man die restaurants zum beispiel öffnet
für einmal die würde eines solchen
vorgehensweise wurde die ausbreitung von
gefährlichen mutationen sogar noch
befördert
da schauen wir uns doch mal an wie viele
geimpfte es denn im moment gibt für die
diese möglichkeiten denn überhaupt
bestehen von denen oder bestehen könnten
jan frederik fischer hat die zahlen
zusammengetragen
bei den impfungen geht es weiter voran
und zwar deutlich mittlerweile haben
mehr als 23,8 millionen menschen ihre
erste spritze bekommen
das entspricht 28,7 prozent der
bevölkerung mehr als 6,7 millionen sind
sogar vollständig geimpft 8,1 prozent
gleichzeitig scheint die dritte welle
abzuflauen das rk ii meldet aktuell
etwas mehr als 7500 neuinfektionen das
sind 3442 weniger als vor einer woche
auch der trend bei der sieben tage
incidents ist positiv lag der wert vor
einer woche noch bei rund 167 liegt er
nun bei 141,4 doch von region zu region
gibt es deutliche unterschiede während
teile von thüringen und sachsen
dunkelrot sind verzeichnen vor allem die
nördlichen bundesländer niedrige
inzidenz aber nicht nur dort gibt es
lichtblicke
bundesweit liegt jetzt sogar jede vierte
region unter der schwelle von 100 und
damit unter dem grenzwert der bundes
notbremse
herr lauterbach nicht nur bei uns
sondern in vielen diskussionen werden
sie als der block down humann bezeichnet
wir sehen die die zahlen gehen runter
die zahlen der geimpften gehen rauf
welche öffnungs pack tiven sehen sie
denn und können sie aus ihrer sicht
mittragen und mitverantworten
ich glaube ich sind vor einer sehr guten
situation hier wird sich die lage
dramatisch entspannen damit rechne ich
in der zweiten maihälfte vielleicht ende
markt weil also wir wissen aus den
erfahrungen aus england aus israel aber
aus den vereinigten staaten dass ab
einer impfquote von ungefähr 40 prozent
und da sind wir also relativ nah dran
was die erste impfung angeht auch die
erstimpfung sich auswirkt auf die
verbreitung des virus in der population
also in der bevölkerung und auswerten
will in zwei wochen drei wochen
tatsächlich diese fälle überschreiten
dann werden die fallzahlen drastisch
sinken
dass sie werden jetzt langsam
zurückgehende zahlen sehen
aber dieser rückgang der fallzahlen wird
sich danach deutlich beschleunigen
so wie man am anfang exponentiell
gewachsen ist gibt es aber einen
bestimmten punkt auch ein exponentielles
schrumpfen weil diejenigen die games
sind die fahren ja aus sowohl als jemand
der andere infizieren kann sie auch als
jemand der sich infizieren kann oder
infiziert werden kann somit auch so geht
das dann auch exponentiell zurück welche
rechne daher mit mit ganz deutlich im
loch wo man unter rückt hier zu vielen
teilen der normalität spätestens anfang
juni also durchaus eine gute perspektive
an der stelle sei auch darauf
hingewiesen dass es viel lob für ihre
sachliche einordnung gibt auch in diesem
live stream wieder das muss ich an der
stelle auch werden und danke vor allem
natürlich auch für diese kommentare
liebe userinnen und user und an nico der
über youtube schreibt
sorry es ist komitee der auch über
youtube schreibt ich würde sagen es ist
längst überfällig die restaurants
erfüllen alle vorgeschriebenen hygiene
konzepte und die leute sollten auch mal
endlich geld verdienen können wenn die
restaurants aufgemacht werden würden
könnte die zufriedenheit der menschen
etwas gesteigert werden herr müller ich
nehme an sie unterschreiben dass jetzt
ist nur die frage unter welchen
voraussetzungen wir haben jetzt geimpfte
wir haben genesene und auch getestet
was machen sie jetzt basteln sie jetzt
schon eigene formulare die man dann
ausfüllen darf akzeptieren sie im presse
akzeptieren sie die low carb akzeptieren
sie die korona waren sie können gerne
kurz ans telefon gehen wenn es wenn es
ihnen hilft oder ist es gar nicht dachte
mir alles genau genau wie wie soll das
denn jetzt praktisch gehen also
lockerungen stehen quasi vor der tür
aber sie also gastronomen haben jetzt
noch mal die aufgabe zu kontrollieren
dass auch alles seine richtigkeit
ja das ist richtig also ich war auch nie
ein verfechter von einem blind links auf
machen dafür ist die sache ist zu
gefährlich und hat man zu viel
verantwortung deshalb finde ich es auch
mal richtig und gute mit bedacht daran
zu gehen und der vertreter lauterbach ja
schon auch ein bisschen die defensive
meinung trotzdem muss ich sagen mir geht
es teilweise ein bisschen zu langsam und
ich glaube wir haben schon einiges auch
versäumt und vor allem auch auf der
technischen seite eben denke ich müsste
müsste man jetzt schon konkretere
konzepte und einheitlichere konzepte
eben haben mit denen die restaurants und
dann auch mit den gesundheitsämtern
neben zusammenarbeiten können um das um
eben dann auch wirklich zu öffnen
und natürlich glaube ich das vielleicht
nicht nur die erste impfung ist sondern
tatsächlich auch ein test meinen wenn
man jetzt in urlaub fliegt
beispielsweise dann sitzt man im großen
flieger mit vielen menschen zusammen
aber alle sind getestet und man sitzt
auch in nach veröffentlichen nahverkehr
im bus mit menschen zusammen die
vielleicht sogar noch nicht mal alle
getestet sind also es ist nicht so dass
wir im leben diese situation eben nicht
mehr haben oder aber nicht mit die
schlangen vor meinem restaurant
anschauen
die da täglich in den supermarkt der
unten im basement ist rein pilgern dann
ist das eben auch einen aufeinander
drängen von menschen und das erlebe ich
dann eben auch im supermarkt und da ist
ebenso die frage ob man das nicht dann
lieber kontrollierter auch in einem
restaurant mit entsprechenden apps und
testungen die mischung aus testungen
impfen der rückverfolgung der genesung
beispielsweise wenn man das alles
zusammen auf einen nenner bringen könnte
kontrollieren könnte sozusagen
und das eben auch in der einen
vereinfachten form für den gastronomen
ablesbar macht über über ein technisches
system über über die handys die sich
einloggen können sobald die schwelle des
restaurants überschritten wird und
betreten wird
das halte ich für extrem wichtig da
jetzt dran zu gehen und genau das zu
forcieren und sagte ich mir auch
gewünscht dass das schon so ein bisschen
früher passiert weil man darf sich auch
nicht ich glaube wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen die leute treffen sich ja
trotzdem und auch jetzt trotz der
ausgang zu beschränkungen
kriegt man es ja mit dass das sich dann
eben vorher getroffen wird und dass das
eben der mensch an sich bestreben danach
hat irgendwie nach dem sozialen
zusammenleben dass er irgendwie dass er
das vielleicht auch braucht und ich
glaube auch die ganzen psychischen
schäden die wir bei den gerade bei den
jungen menschen und abitur ihren und
jetzt kein abi machen dass wir das alles
noch gar nicht abschätzen können und
dass das auch eine zufriedenheit der
seele eben auch zu einem gesunden körper
gehört und da von daher glaube ich schon
dass das jetzt wichtig ist da sehr sehr
schnell daran zu gehen und das bereit zu
halten oder da gemeinsam eine
einheitliche lösung zu finden mit der
jeder gastronom sage ich jetzt mal
aufmachen kann und natürlich gibt es die
einen die terrasse haben die anderen die
vielleicht keine terrasse haben dann
muss man natürlich auch ein bisschen
drauf achten
aber ich würde ich würde schon sagen
dass wir da jetzt schnell ran müssen
ja herr lauterbach dann ist die frage
warum haben wir das denn nicht schon
alles warum hat sich niemand und diese
praktische fragen gekümmert wir haben
einen impf gipfel vor zwei wochen erlebt
da haben bund und länder gesagt wir
haben jetzt plötzlich ganz viele
geimpfte was machen wir denn eigentlich
mit denen wir sollten mal über deren
freiheiten nachdenken jetzt plötzlich
haben wir geimpfte die freiheiten
bekommen stellen wir fest
wir haben überhaupt kein instrumentarium
mit dem die vorweisen können dass die
geimpft sind was einheitlich ist warum
gibt es das noch nicht
naja es ist ja nicht so sondern es gibt
natürlich die eben raus war so und diese
impfausweise kann man vorzeige man kann
auch lebens bescheinigungen vor zeiten
und es wird ja auch andere elektronische
lösungen jetzt gearbeitet so dass man
diese bescheinigungen davon war so
einscannen kann beziehungsweise das ist
dann eine elektronische also eintritt
gibt das muss nicht sein es kann sogar
die bewohner waren app sein verlangen
geburtstag sind daran wird mit hochdruck
gearbeitet das wird auch weiter sein und
viel vor hat das ja auch nicht hin
gemacht weil wir haben ja noch nicht so
viele also beginnt das kann ja nur um
die dort geimpften gehen dass es die
geben wird das war ja klar denn wir
haben ja immer gesagt der weg aus der
pandemie sind die geimpften da muss ich
mir doch vorher mal überlegen was ich
mache wenn es soweit ist und zwar nicht
dann wenn es soweit ist so
vorher denn ich glaube nicht dass die
leute jetzt alle mit diesem gelben
abgeglitten impfpass in der handtasche
durch deutschland reisen werden um sich
dann for h&m oder vor dem restaurant von
nelson müller als geimpfte aus werden
das ist auch nicht deutschland im jahr
2021 na ja das stimmt aber an den sie
sich also an den frankreich wie ein
roter faden an dem europäischen infos
was also wird ja fieberhaft gearbeitet
ist das lösen hat in der eu rat am 21
januar und jetzt haben wir an jürgen may
ja also wie gesagt an also ich kann nur
soviel sagen dass sie nicht schneller
vorangegangen ist an die habs nicht
geregelt
es ist aber ich blicke immer nach vorn
ich kritisiere niemann denn ich hatte
nicht damit auffassung darüber
nachzudenken was natürlich schneller
machen können aber jetzt müssen wir nach
vorne blicken und schauen dass mit einem
solchen delikt wurde ich im europäischen
ausland schnell wie möglich bekommen
weil das muss ja in der regelung seien
die für alle europäer gut funktioniert
wo man womit man sich also in jedes haus
europäische restaurant und in dieses
europäischen kaffee und geschäfte
registrieren kann
und also eine solche lösung brauchen er
bringt aber nichts desto trotz kann nur
noch mal darauf hinweisen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wenn man also privilegien auch
beim restaurantbesuch zum beispiel
müssten den außenbereich also erlebnis
wird ja bald kommen dann kann man auch
den ganz normalen ebenfalls falsch
beziehungsweise mechaniker kurz
erreichen so lange wie die europäische
liegt vor die ich so noch nie vor
herr müller sie hatten was auf dem
herzen und auf der zunge
genau ich glaube einfach ich bin auch
kein fan davon leben zurück zu treten
und zurück zu kritisieren aber ich stehe
halt doch immer die tendenz fest dass es
leichter ist sage ich jetzt mal zu sagen
wir lieber noch nicht und noch verhalten
und es ist noch zu früh aber ich glaube
wichtig ist die der focus den den fokus
müssen wir doch auf die
auf technik setzen weil das zieht sich
doch leider wie ein roter faden ja auch
schon lange und auch nach wie vor durch
durch die erkrankungen ja auch
beispielsweise durch also ich habe das
selber erlebt dass man dann eben auch
krankt aber dann wie sehr umständlich
per postalisch sozusagen zugestellt
bekommen dass man zu hause bleibt aber
dass das läuft nicht digital oder dass
man dem auch hinterher rennen muss sage
ich mal wenn man wieder genesen ist es
unheimlich schwer das sozusagen zu holen
und das ist für mich ja eigentlich zieht
sich das ein bisschen wie ein roter
faden durch alle das ist einfach wir
sind nicht auf der technischen höhe um
es mal ein gegengewicht zu lockdown und
verschärfungen zu setzen und ich finde
das schade ich finde es wichtig
zeitgleich bei aller vorsicht die finde
ich auch wichtig zu sagen darauf was
haben wir für möglichkeiten haben wir
die und schöpfen wir die denn auch
wirklich aus und das finde ich so schade
dass wir da nicht am puls der zeit sind
und die die nicht ausschöpfen und ich
glaube je länger das eben auch braucht
desto desto mehr schäden werden wir
haben und die die können wir jetzt auch
noch gar nicht so beziffern und sehen
die werden wahrscheinlich erst später
deutlich und eben auch sicherlich
insolvenzen im restaurant schließungen
und ich habe es gerade schon erwähnte
die mitarbeiter die eben natürlich dann
auch schauen wie sie eben weiter kommen
wie sie
ja weiter damit umgehen dann blicken wir
mal in die zukunft und auf das was in
zeitnah noch möglich sein soll nämlich
urlaub zumindest in einigen
bundesländern oder in einigen ländern
dieser welt an seinem stern fasst
zusammen nach ganz vielen grauen monaten
voller virus sorgen heute mal eine gute
nachricht etwa in diesem hotel in
grainau landkreis garmisch-partenkirchen
ab dem 21
mai dürfen sie hier wieder aufmachen
sollte die inzidenz bei den
neuansteckungen unter 100 bleiben
wir freuen uns natürlich dass man jetzt
auch spielen dürfen ist jetzt recht
schneller termin der auf uns zukäme ist
aber auch dass wärme schaffen die
schwierigkeiten seien jetzt mitarbeiter
finden mitarbeiter einstellen urlaub im
hotel außengastronomie öffnen alles mit
hygiene und test konzepten und nur dann
wenn die instanzen mit spielen in den
städten und landkreisen bayern ist nicht
nur ein tourismusland aber es ist für
die menschen glaube ich auch
psychologisch und seelisch wichtig an
dass wir eine perspektive haben und ich
denke das konzept jetzt ist eine gute
mischung aus vorsicht und optimismus
eine ganz ähnliche planung auch in
niedersachsen schon ab kommender woche
dürfte in einigen regionen eine menge
aufgemacht werden auch die hotels
zunächst aber nur für gäste aus
niedersachsen wir sind nach wie vor sehr
vorsichtig jede dieser
lockerungsmaßnahmen über die wir
sprechen sind mit 345 unterschiedlichen
sicherung versehen
insbesondere erwarten wir in ganz vielen
fällen tagesaktuelle kontrollierte
negativer tests negativ tests und ab in
den urlaub bald also möglich mancher
orts in deutschland was aber ist mit
sonne und strand im ausland vor allem
die tourismus länder in europa drängen
der griechische tourismus minister heute
auf werbetour in berlin
es ist sehr wichtig dass der tourismus
zwischen griechenland und deutschland
wieder in gang kommt das ist auch
wichtig für europa der tourismus ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer wirtschaft
wirtschaft arbeitsplätze endlich
erholung es hängt viel dran
experten warnen aber auch zuviel
lockerung könnte die virus zahlen auch
schnell wieder nach oben treiben
bevor wir hier in der runde weiter
machen herzlichen dank von mir an
joachim lotz der mich darauf hinweist
dass der impf gipfel letzte woche war
und nicht vor zwei wochen vielen dank
herr ott sie haben völlig recht aber man
verliert das gefühl für raum und zeit in
dieser pandemie danke schön herr
lauterbach wir haben gesehen bayern
öffnet für touristen über pfingsten
baden württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann sagt das virus wird und
wurde verbreitet durch reisen es ist ja
erst durch reisen überhaupt auf der welt
verbreitet worden
da ist vorsicht geboten sind sie was das
thema reisen über pfingsten angeht team
söder oder team kretschmann
also ich glaube das sind tatsächlich es
kalt ist und es kommt darauf an wo man
reist also verreisen beispielsweise in
gebiete wo sich mutationen verbreiten
sind natürlich riskant war wie die
mutation dann nach deutschland
einbringen würden hier kommt
insbesondere länder in frage wo sich die
südafrikanische variante verbreitet hat
hier würde für die ersten die er so noch
keine zweite impfung haben eine große
gefahr darstellen
aber auch die brasilianische variante
ist hier zu bedenken die indische
variante ebenfalls also überall wo die
brasilianische die die die ähnliche oder
auch die südafrikanischen variante
vorherrschen ist aus meiner sicht das
heißt im film hat man mit größter
vorsicht zu sehen und da durfte auch was
man sich die karten das licht nach der
einreise nicht aufgerufen
für diejenigen die geimpft sind ergeben
sich natürlich andere möglichkeiten wie
für die nicht geimpften diejenigen die
geimpft sind und zurückkommen
wir müssen nicht in quarantäne und also
die sind auch normalerweise von der test
lichtern auszunehmen weil also der die
die testung oder im prinzip also ein zu
geringes risiko zeigen würde
es waren zu wenige test positiv was man
erwarten würde und ich hatte irgendwie
schon ausgeführt
diejenigen die trotzdem infiziert sind
in der regel nicht anstecken das gilt
allerdings nicht für gebiete mutationen
sind wo die impfungen und vollständig
wirken oder
also ihre wirkung nicht genau untersucht
ist das heißt wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dann wird es schon eine art
zweiklassengesellschaft geben was das
reisen angeht im sommer und vielleicht
jetzt auch schon in den pfingstferien
nämlich geimpfte und nicht geimpfte und
damit auch die die noch kein impfangebot
haben obwohl sie sich gerne impfen
lassen würden
die müssen dann zu hause bleiben oder
die zusätzlichen regeln einhalten die
dann gelten die sie gerade genannt haben
genau wie müssen die zusätzlichen regeln
einhalten das ist tatsächlich so dass
diejenigen die jetzt noch keine impfung
bekommen konnten
dass die einen nachteil haben bei
bestimmten hasen was sie ihren bei der
rückkehr aus der aus dem reiseland
getestet werden müssen oder je nachdem
wo sie gewesen sind sogar in quarantäne
müssen und das entfällt je nachdem wo
man gewesen ist für die gesten das ist
eine ungleichbehandlung aber sie ist
einfach epidemiologisch geboten weil die
alternative wäre ja die habe zwei
alternativen basis stellt die
alternative wäre dass wir die regeln
auch für die geimpften also gelten
lassen nach dem motto in den geimpften
darf es auch wohl es medizinisch nicht
notwendig ist ideologisch nicht
notwendig ist das kein vorteil entstehen
was wäre nichts anderes als eine
bestrafung der geimpften wir wollten sie
wurden dann quasi behandelt wie und
diensten aber diese behandlung
eigentlich nötig oder wir machen es so
dass wir sagen naja den ungeimpften darf
kein nachteil entstehen weil es solche
ungleichbehandlung ist nicht hinzunehmen
der und gamestar kann genauso heißt wie
der dienste dann könnten wir aber sehr
schnell in eine neue welle von
infektionen geraten und konnten den
erfolg gefährden weil wir werden im
sommer auch noch viele haben die nicht
geimpft sind diejenigen die siert wieder
nicht impfen lassen wollen oder das ihm
angeboten nicht jetzt schon sondern
später wahrnehmen wollen und auch
diejenigen die übrigens gar nicht
geimpft werden können erfolgreich die
gibt es ja auch mit dem montag und somit
also müssen wir vorsichtig sein und
daher gibt es hier eine schlechte
möglichkeit nämlich
hier die games sind die uhren gehen
ungleich behandeln und zwei noch
schlechtere alternativen
das ist kein schönes schlusswort von
ihnen was nicht an ihnen liegt
lauterbach aber ich würde gerne so zu
sagen aber das haben sie jetzt auch
schon oft erlebt in diesen gesprächen
der die letzte frage würde ich gerne
anhand anhand müller stellen nämlich die
wann rechnen sie damit ihre ersten gäste
wieder nicht nur beliefern sondern auch
bei sich begrüßen zu dürfen ja ich hoffe
dass wir gegen juni wieder aufmachen es
ist ja auch so und das ist glaube ich
auch
geht da darf ich wahrscheinlich für
viele gastronomen sprechen so ein
schnelles aufmachen ist ja auch
logistisch für uns immer immer schwierig
also ich glaube für die gastronomen ist
es wichtig so eine planungssicherheit zu
haben zu überlegen wann kann man dann
können wir welche schritte einleiten um
dann eben wieder aufmachen zu können sie
auch viele mitarbeiter in der kurzarbeit
das muss man regeln müssen auch abläufe
eben auch wieder eingespielt werden
überlegt werden neu gedacht werden
manche sind auch im umbau und haben ihre
terrasse eben dementsprechend fordert
schauen dass überhaupt eine haben also
von daher tun uns so ein paar wochen die
wir dann eben noch haben schon gut an
das ist es vielleicht in den in den
urlaubsregionen oder bei den großen
hotels dann muss man sicherlich auch
nochmal unterscheiden
aber ich persönlich gehe von juni aus
und ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
man so über alle systeme hat dass es
natürlich für die geimpften sicherlich
auch ein vorteil geben kann und darf
aber eben dann
abgesehen vom reisen von einem
restaurantbesuch daneben mit negativ
testen oder auch am besten noch mit
einem pcr-test da noch einer digitalen
lösung dieser gap zwischen geimpft und
ungeimpft dann auch vielleicht gar nicht
so da ist und wir nicht unbedingt von
einer zwei klassen gesellschaft sprechen
müssen
jedes mal wenn wir das natürlich wieder
anwerfen wird das auch vielleicht noch
mehr so empfunden
ich kann mir gar nicht so vorstellen auf
die gesellschaft das überhaupt so
empfindet weil tatsächlich biologisch
gesehen ist es ja einfach nur mal so der
eine ist geimpfte andere wird dann
hoffentlich auch geimpft und wenn dann
sozusagen kreis dass diese dass die
priorisierung aufgehoben wird vielleicht
irgendwann und dann doch viel mehr
menschen die möglichkeit haben geimpft
zu werden
wenn das gut erklärt und begleitet wird
glaube ich dass das dann eben auch nicht
zu so einer spaltung führte nelson
müller vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen und ihre meinung zu
diesem thema und karl lauterbach auch an
sie nochmal ganz herzlichen dank fürs
mit diskutieren und die expertise und an
sie zu hause auch ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre konstruktiven kommentare an
vielen stellen und ich freue mich auf
das nächste mal machen sie's gut abend
schön abend